So everyone knows that Santa Claus lives
at the North Pole,
more specifically,
he actually lives in these full bod
archipelago,
which is the northern most human
settlement in the world is the only
place on earth where you don't need a
visa to ends up.
However,
there are 2,600 inhabitants,
must be totally self sufficient and they
also have to carry a gun whenever they
leave the main town.
This isn't a defending themselves from
each other,
but rather to defend themselves from the
polar bears,
which tends to roam around the region.
Bones which belongs to the Kingdom of
Norway,
is the hot spot of a political dispute
with Russia.
Interestingly,
this frozen region has a pretty good
chance of becoming the next Dubai,
although certainly not when it comes to
the web,
Svalbard has one of the biggest oil beds
in the world.
Further,
they are the gateway to the Arctic
routes,
which might just become one of the most
important pathways for international
trade.
And this is why small bond is more than
an ordinary territorial disputes.
We're talking about a potential new cold
war involving the United States,
Canada and even China,
and today that's the story we're going
to tell you about
once.
Imagine alarms with open doors for
immigrants,
no matter where they come from.
A place where a military presence is
forbidden because it's a demilitarized
zone.
A place which is a fiscal haven has the
average salary of Norway.
Well,
this place that exists,
and it's called SFO boss Andy.
Yes,
it's at the North Pole.
Also,
if you want to go to svalbard bad,
there's no need to worry about catching
a cold or the flu.
The extremely cold temperatures make it
impossible for viruses and bacteria to
stay.
Didn't that cap?
It's a long year.
The and you can find the world's biggest
sneaker collection wants to try cognac
from the 19th century or maybe a
whiskey.
Well,
Colin's Burger pub is the place to go,
so let me introduce you to it's owner,
Steve Dorfman.
Many,
many different people from many
different nations working with many
different things.
First of all,
one of the biggest is absolutely the
coal mining company take have been the
coal mining company for 100 years
actually,
and today there is more and more people
working with the tourist business
service like a restaurant,
but also there is a lot of science going
on on a small board,
so at the beginning of the 20th century
that was a no man's land and only some
whale fishing and with daggers at this
place.
Nevertheless,
after the first world war and not all
countries signed,
something called the small batch Tracy
in treaty,
it is written,
the Norway hold sovereignty over the
territory,
bounce them off some restrictions.
For one,
they consented,
met Rami.
They also can't build a headquarters
already strongholds as they must allow
every citizen and every company,
no matter where they are from to enter
the island and exploited snapple
resources,
and this is how to cities were born.
On the one hand,
we have long year billion where the
majority of the population is Norwegian.
On the other hands,
there is Barrons Burg with a Russian
majority.
In both of these cases,
these started as coal mining settlements
that every year there is a or two times
a year there's like a sports contest
between the settlements.
Between bars.
Yeah.
Tonight you might be wondering where
executives of these mining companies pay
their taxes in Svalbard?
Well,
despite being a Norwegian territory this
fall about trees,
he forbids any country from taxing the
profits.
This means that citizens pay the minimum
required amount to finance their own
governance.
In other words,
fall could be considered a fiscal haven.
They have no VAT in their corporate tax
goes up to 16 percent,
which is even lower than seeing a pause
the last 10,
15 years have been a lot of people
coming from many different places.
Today.
There is like 46 different nations
living in,
in settlement along all these different
nations.
Live very good together with each other.
Um,
and Namibia we have every year there is
a lawyer as a title on a celebrating
there you have the Russian and you have
the Swedish one,
but make no mistake.
All those tie,
Russian and Swedish people are not
coming to a folder just for the low
taxes or the coal mines,
as you might imagine,
getting cold from the North Pole to the
rest of the world is pretty expensive
and it's not a very profitable business.
Yes,
small barred coal mine halts production
and so now you might be wondering,
well,
if Kohl's nonprofitable while there so
many people going back,
it's probably not for the balmy weather
during winter.
Svalbard has a never ending night.
Weather is not even a single minute of
daylight.
Of course,
several people who live that work in
science research centers,
which are based on the archipelago.
Indeed,
since 2008 Svalbard has hosted the
global seed vault.
This is a storage location,
people mainly by the bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and Microsoft in this
vault.
They restored a vast collection of seeds
from most of the plants that exist in
the world in case of a nuclear
holocaust.
Mankind would be able to reply on the
planet,
thanks to this great volt,
but this is still not the reason why
[inaudible] is so important.
In fact,
there is something more interesting than
cold polar bears,
science or even Santa Claus Sense.
The Arctic holds an estimated 13 percent
or $90,
billion barrels of the world's
undiscovered conventional oil resources
and 30 percent of its undiscovered
conventional natural gas resources.
Ah,
yes,
they have oil.
That's not only that.
Let's imagine for a second that you want
to ship some goods from London to Tokyo
today.
The fullest discreet would be to take
this one,
but imagine you could instead do it
using this room.
You see what's going on here.
This is almost half of the distance.
This means less spending and faster
logistics technology and climate change
are making it possible to travel through
the Arctic Ocean,
and this would be a turning point in
international trade and one day this is
going to be a reality,
and on this day,
Svalbard has the highest chance of
becoming the architect capital.
The rest of the islands belonged to
Russia and to have no human population.
Greenland's on the other hand,
has a chaotic legal system.
Svalbard has a strong political system
and good infrastructure.
The proof is in this very interview with
Steve,
which was conducted through skype,
but do we just a moment because the best
pass,
it's yet to come.
The frozen war for the Arctic Arctic oil
is under the seat.
This means the above.
The ground lands of Svalbard has no oil
beds,
at least that we know of.
All their wealth is on these so called
continental shelf.
This is the underwater lands maps,
which extends from a continence no
deeper than 200 meters.
According to international law,
the continental shelf belongs to the
country that is attached to and of
course this includes all of the
resources beneath,
so it should be the government of the
country who decides whether they want to
exploit this resource or what
not,
and yes,
both Norway and small bonds archipelagos
are on the same continental shelf.
Therefore in normal conditions,
the Norwegian government would have
sovereignty over this oil.
But remember what we said about this
fall.
Barge treating every country can exploit
the resources and Norway.
You can do nothing to stop them.
So what exactly is the problem here?
Well,
that's the treaty actually says nothing
about the continental shelf or anything
under the water at all,
at the end of the day when it was signed
and no one was really thinking about
extracting oil from the bottom of the
ocean,
and this is why news like this makes
people so nervous.
Russia believes no way is violating the
small bird treaty.
When the Norwegian government opens
three blocks for oil drilling in the
Barents Sea close to the Arctic Arctic
Pelican.
In summary,
Russia says the continental shelf of
small bald.
It shouldn't be ruled by the treaty and
to be exploited by any country,
but nobody claims that since the legal
texts didn't contain anything about
this,
the oil and the rights to extract it
belong to them and now we come to
Russia.
I might still be thinking that this
North Pole thing,
business more story.
One of the things for backup remix and
diplomats to have discussions about
while having dinner,
but the truth is that Vladimir Putin,
vice prime minister Dmitry ragas
intimate,
a controversial visit to the
archipelago.
It's the Cold War in the Arctic.
Russia says it's deputy prime minister.
Had every right to visit a Norwegian
island near the North Pole,
despite travel restrictions imposed on
him over the conflict in Ukraine,
Norway has condemned the trip and ask
for an explanation.
This visit turns fall bald in we
fashionable tourist destination about
the Russians and the last two years it's
fall bumps.
Tourism has increased 100 percent.
Now,
as I mentioned at the beginning that all
to villages on the main islands.
One is Norwegian ends,
one is Russian,
the Russian one is gold Barron's bag and
there's a population of less than 500
people.
Incredibly.
In 2015 alone,
they had more than 60,000 tourists.
Visited.
Designer.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Now you might be wondering why is the
Russian tourism is so important to
Svalbard?
Well,
that's because it helps to retain
population,
but did it in.
In,
in Boris,
bu there are,
there are,
there are more on the,
like a system very heavy there where the
coal company is everything and you're
eating in the content and it's not
necessarily to buy your food so face.
So for a better understanding and the
Russian sentiments,
there is no currency.
The mining company,
it takes care of everything,
something like this didn't used to
happen in the Norwegian settlements to
but then tourism staunton that brought
all new kinds of businesses and as many
different people.
So they are in the beginning of a
process,
on the same way as we have been doing it
in longer beyond the last,
uh,
25,
30 years.
But do you watch out because here we're
talking about oil and influence in
what's my,
it's become one of the main ocean
shipping routes in the world.
In fact,
even China is trying to buy property
yet,
but that's a whole different issue and
that's something we're going to talk
about in a future video.
So we've given you our opinion here,
a visual politic,
and now we'd love to know yours.
What do you think of small bots?
Do you think it will become a new ones?
Are All the frozen Dubai?
Should No.
Wait,
let's Russia explain to this foul body
oil.
A lot of snow in the comments section
below,
we'd love to hear from you.
And don't forget that we put our brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
So do not forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos.
Also,
if you did like this video,
please do give it a thumbs up below.
It helps us out and as always I'll see
you next time and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast.